Chappelle
Rock
fur one
Mulaney Maniscalco
Frazier Hart Netflix paid them
handsomely and with whatever money they
had left over they got this guy
up in Louisiana I grew up a lot of
homophobia I grew up with a guy hated
gay people he was obsessed with gay guys
taking the rainbow that was like his big
beef gay guys took the rainbow I'm like
that might be the gayest complaint I've
ever heard my entire life
I'm doing all right you know I had sex
with my wife today or she calls it micro
dosing and uh
I remember one time I left the abortion
clinic with a lady and there's a guy
protesting he goes you're a goddamn
murderer I was like Wow about murder are
really more just hired a hit man
even treat their dicks like kids we wash
it we take care of it we name it we go
you want to see a photo people go no
thank you
the only difference is you beat your kid
at the mall nobody stops you
Mark Norman Soup To Nuts another reason
why women are better than men you don't
see a lot of female School shooters
what's going on there I Googled it
there's been two
anybody ever heard of them whether it's
gun violence or the WNBA
nobody's watching these female Shooters
the special he's been waiting for
all right comedy